it is now over a week since the debris
from Titan was found and this was the
first time we've heard from those at the
very heart of a long hard mission
I have to apologize we're we're still
demobilizing
it's a lot of emotions people are tired
they had always hoped that it would be a
rescue but too quickly it became clear
that it would not
shortly after arriving on the sea floor
we discovered the debris
of the Titan submersible
of course we continue to document the
site
and by 12 o'clock
sadly a rescue turned into a recovery
this was a chance for the team behind
this Odysseus 6K to explain their role
because it was this tethered submersible
and the experts who made it and who
operated which allowed a hugely complex
recovery to take place
but a sense of the number of agencies
and companies involved three U.S
military transport planes were on hand
to fly 32 000 kilograms of equipment
from Buffalo New York to Newfoundland
from there as part of a Non-Stop
operation that would last 10 days
Odysseus was transported to the search
Zone when we arrived on site there was a
fleet of ships there we came in next to
a ship called Deep energy an industry
ship
their vehicle was at 2 700 meters they
were not capable of going deeper there
were no answers for why Titans Voyage to
Titanic went so wrong that will be for
the investigators above all this was a
reflection of a tight community of
submariners explorers Marine experts who
went to save some of their number but
who in the end could not we were focused
at the job at hand
that's what we do that's what all of
these people do we were laser focused on
rescue
with this recovery will come some
closure for the families of those on
board Mark Stone Sky News